there are two ways of thinking of a
robot one is the science fiction robot
is the same fiction robot because he
looks like us behaves like us and as
things like us is the robot who actually
drives the car because it has a body
like ours and can drive from here to
there because it reasons like us he has
our skills there is as I said science
fiction then there's the other robot the
robot that doesn't look like us doesn't
think like us doesn't behave like us but
it can right you drive the car from here
to there because there's plenty of
information maps sensors satellite and
controls of all kinds together with
algorithms and databases they make sure
that the particular journey is
successful there is the robot that's
going to be successful in the future
because we are enveloping the world
around it's very simple abilities we saw
in the other video how time is changing
in terms of hyper history I'd like to
tell you something about how our
conception of space is changing and
therefore in terms of how environment is
being shaped today this has got to do
with the success of artificial
intelligence AI or as I rather would
call it smart technologies suppose we
want to summarize the history of AI in
the past 60 years or so it would look
something like this you have on the one
end
AI as part of the engineering department
this means that it doesn't matter
whether this really AI what it matter is
that it does a good job the joke is
don't ask whether submarine can actually
swim as long as it does what is supposed
to do is it really swimming or not
that's not a shoe or you could have AI
as part of the cognitive science
department at this point it is not about
the job it's about the non-biological
implementation of intelligence maybe
it's just a little bit of intelligence
and it's not as intelligence as your dog
but it would be an enormous success if
he were intelligent at all now this has
been a great success this has been a
complete disaster
we have no intelligence whatsoever to
speak in terms of AI today as you would
expect it from economy science
perspective but we have amazing smart
machines in terms of engineering the
sky's the limit there are more and more
machines more and more computers of all
kinds doing things that we thought were
impossible just yesterday
so what's the explanation well the
explanation is something that I would
like to call enveloping the world the
term comes from robotics and it's quite
simple the best thing to do is to
introduce it with an analogy you have
several robots in your kitchen
they're called dishwasher fridge and so
on now a dishwasher does exactly what
happens in an industrial building you
build a whole world around a very simple
gadget inside what you do is to
transform a whole environment into
something that is friendly to the very
stupid little robot inside who goes No
chew chew chew chew chunk wait a little
bit of soap for a long time nobody in
his right mind certainly not me would
wash dishes the way a dishwasher does it
don't even try this at home you have
your agent here which is quite stupid
and you have a complex environment here
instead of trying to make the agent
adapt to the environment you make the
environment friendly to this stupid
agent you build a whole box around some
turning bits in a bit of soap or you
make sure that there are enough elements
in the environment so that your car can
drive from here to there without you
being in charge drones can fly all over
the place without having a pilot on
board your smartphone can communicate
with a smart device without you having
to constantly intervene in other words
we are enveloping the world to make sure
that the
agent stupid can work there and
enveloping robotics is the 3d space
within which an industrial robot can
operate successfully for example
building a car needing something or
solving something else so this is the
idea that we are transforming the
environment into an AI friendly
environment by enveloping in around the
agent in question a long time ago say in
the late 40s in the 50s grandma used to
walk inside the computer she had to
change the program using a screwdriver
now her daughter walked out of the
computer she started at least since the
70s to sit in front of the computer and
programming or interacting with the
computer was a text-based idea some of
you will even remember DOS a generation
later we are back to a mix between the
two now interacting with a computer has
become again something that you do with
your hands a little bit like grandma
used to do it with a screwdriver but at
the same time you are inside the
computer again the computer is around
you and whenever you walk from home to
the office through Starbucks you are
connected 24/7 aims to pick up the
component of the sensor but there's no
guarantee it's gonna pick up a component
exactly in the sensor access to those
kind of infrastructures and you can hack
into those infrastructures in such a way
as to disrupt anything this normal life
in a particular country